tonight a special edition of bang goes
the theory to help you improve your
brain six months ago we launched the
world's biggest scientific experiment
ever to find out if brain training games
really can improve your brain so can you
train your brain bang goes the theory is
a science magazine show that goes out on
BBC one and we cover all aspects of
science we basically put science to the
test
and remind people that if they're in any
way curious about the world around them
they are in fact scientists well the BBC
has a website called lab UK whose remit
is to marry scientific data or new
scientific ideas for research with
scientists and with the general public
in order to provide big sample sizes so
they had come up with the idea to test
where the brain training games actually
work so along with bang goes the theory
we approached Adrian Owen and the
Alzheimer Society to see if they would
be interested in helping us you know set
up this math experiment I saw it as a
great opportunity because brain training
is something that many thousands of
people do now and if you really wanted
to test whether it works or not it
seemed as so involving many many people
was really a very good way to do it by
collaborating with BBC lab UK we were
able to involve many many thousands of
people getting training in different
ways to really try and nail down if
brain training works and if so how does
it work sort of holy grail of brain
training really is that they will
transfer to other types of cognitive
functions so we all know that if you
practice something you get good at it so
that you know there's no doubt that if
you do a brain training game you'll get
better at that brain training again the
question we were really try to get at is
does it lead to any general benefits in
other areas of life in other aspects of
cognitive function when you actually
look for hard evidence of these claims
by that I mean proper trials publishing
scientific journals the evidence for
people like you and me is pretty thin
so we decided to take matters into our
own hands now six months ago right here
aren't bang we launched an experiment to
find out if brain training games really
do improve our overall mental abilities
so eleven and a half thousand people
between the ages of 18 and 60 took part
in this math experiment we basically
separated them out into three groups we
had a control group that took part in
just regular internet's activities a
group that took part in reasoning
exercises and another group that took
part in non reasoning exercise so we
could be sure that all three groups were
using a computer for about the same
amount of time every day but only two of
the groups were doing any sort of formal
brain training one of them was very
targeted on aspects of reasoning and the
other was rather more general and we
benchmark tests than beforehand to see
their general brainpower abilities then
they trained and then we retested them
these are cognitive tests that we've
developed in Cambridge and we've used in
many experiments involving functional
imaging and studies of
neuropsychological populations we know
that they're very sensitive to cognitive
change and we use these as our real
measure of whether the brain training
that people subsequently went on to do
would have any effect
okay it's time for the moment of truth
now we already know brain training games
make you better at those games but do
they improve your brain power like some
of the commercial games imply each of
the two training groups did of course
improve on the test that they were
actually training on this is practice
we've known about this for for many many
years and you get better at what what
you practice that the key result was
that this didn't transfer six weeks
remember of brain training thousands of
you across the nation did you do any
better than our control group are you
ready to find out let's find out
where is it gonna stop that's all of us
the same as our control room can you
believe it
people were very surprised when they
found out I was actually quite surprised
when I found out and there were a few
cynics in the crowd that when we asked
them before you know do you think this
works they were like probably not but I
think they were probably just second
guessing us most people in in the studio
that day were quiet aghast when we told
them actually there's absolutely no
difference in your cognitive skills one
of the really interesting things about
these data is that not only were there
negligible transfer effects to other
cognitive domains but also that was the
case when the training tasks and the the
benchmarking tests were really very
closely related to one another so you
know one example is we had a memory
training task that was rather like the
classic parlor game of pears where you
have to remember where two objects that
are similar are placed in a deck of
cards people detrained of that task
didn't get any better at a benchmarking
test that in a similar way required that
they remember the locations of objects
you know it's like learning an
instrument if you want to get better at
the violin then you know practice the
violin but you're not going to get any
better playing the trumpet by practicing
the violin I think when we set out to do
this math experiment and launch it on
bang and then you know with the view to
make this one-hour special I don't think
we realized how big this was already to
guess and you know I learned so much but
I think to be doing it with someone as
esteemed as Adrienne to have a paper
published in nature is a little bit
surreal and and and absolutely fantastic
for us to run an experiment like this
using traditional laboratory methods
where we would bring participants in and
sit them down in front of a dedicated
computer it would have taken us years
and years and years to do it by just
putting up a website inviting people to
participate via the BBC programs have
raised that you know the profile you
know allowed us to do it in six weeks
and that's something you know I think
there are many different applications of
that
that type of approach
you